wirst einfach bodenburg weiße er sagt
einfach macht die keinen bogen
und dann hatte einfach ein bogen jallohs
sollen wieder auf ihn drauf so leute das
epische battle beginnen
[Musik]
ich schwöre ich werde gleich oder timer
geht aus so das heißt wir gehen es
weiter an die oberfläche ja wünschen
also ja ich muss eben weg hoch finden
wie komme ich denn hier raus und ich bin
sondern schlucht drin man wie monster
drops kassiert okay leute wenn ihr das
ganze hätte wahrscheinlich in der
dritten folge und hier ist gerade erst
mal so ein arschloch er seit ihr guckt
ihr wahrscheinlich gar die dritte folge
des bettes das ist jetzt die zeit folge
wo wir jetzt nach oben bauen nach oben
gehen max und ich und dann werden wir
uns oben irgendwo treffen und dann den
den krieg todes machen
aber lassen wir noch ein bisschen zeit
weil ich bin ja ich die nativen höhle
drin
ja ich trete ich jetzt nein junge ich
muss doch erst mal noch zu meinen sachen
in meiner pace
ich meine wenn ich 30 minuten moderat
[Musik]
professionalität an ganzkörper wo bin
ich denn hier raus gegangen
das war doch hier irgendwo wir können
einen rechten ich werfe nicht tätigt
schnell hoch her
junge ich muss aber zu meinen sachen
marx ich meine sachen sind doch um bei
mein base ich hab's aber langsam nicht
weil ich nenne mal ja dann ich brauche
mal ganz kurz und kräftig die junge das
kann doch nicht sein eigentlich da hat
man eine halbe stunde dann muss man ihn
wir aus dann tp nicht mit der antike
nicht mehr
tp mich nach oben und dann muss ich aber
noch ganz kurzem ein crafting tablet
laufen
das ist ein ganz kurz darauf vorbereiten
okay aber nicht dass du mich jetzt eine
lava teleportiert so ok wo wir stehen da
noch nichts
ich habe sogar kommt man ja ich habe
sich gratis
jetzt muss ich mich vorbereiten
ich habe also ein paar minuten kann er
sagen wir fertig mit vorbereitet und
dann fertig hat einfach ich bin ich echt
ehrlich ja ich habe nichts mehr zu tun
ich habe also ich habe nichts mehr was
ich machen könnte ja dann heißt nicht
jetzt vorn oder so den haben wir
erreicht haben beim befreien
aber die kann ich mir noch schlachten
hier mir vorstellen dass du es für danke
bitte so jo ist die chance dass skelette
bogen droppen also nicht nicht so hoch
ist
ich merke gerade okay max wo wir uns
treffen
jasper okay weil wir sagen wir laufen
jetzt beide zum spor komme allmählich
machen du okay gut
natürlich bin klappt beim zweiten mit
den höheren sinn kommen ich gucke auf
den spot kuppel okay
ich mag's wo bist du ich komme jetzt
gespannt wo bist du ich komme zum sparen
junge der fahrtwind so alles klar
dann sind wir bereit wären wir gehen
jetzt mal bei den dieses born gebäude
rein und dann haben wir zehn sekunden
weg wie dumm läuft auf die zombies okay
max ja passt auf mich hören dass sein
alter also auch für mich getötet hat
ich habe nicht getötet junge ich habe
ohne witz ich hab dich auch nie
angelogen als ich gesagt habe ich ja
keine diamanten ich habe alle diamanten
in den letzten vier minuten gefunden
aber dann immer ich habe eine 7 diamant
quelle gefunden
ich habe insgesamt einfach mal jemand
diamanten gefunden
nein und dann doch ich habe drei quellen
gefunden alter wo es steht also wie viel
zeit geben wir uns ja junge wir laufen
jetzt hier dann eine richtung da sagen
wir mal 320 und ich geben hier hin
du bist einfach ein bisschen dahin so
stoppt jetzt noch jetzt los du hast
einfach ein bogen ehrenburg weiße er
sagt einfach macht die keinen bogen
und dann hat er einfach ein bogen
jallohs sollen wir auf ihn drauf ja so
leute das epische battle beginnt ja das
wollte ich auch erst machen aber du
kannst einfach nicht ungehindert weiter
das war schon mal ein dummer anfangen
ich kann einfach nicht angehen dass
dürfen junge das bringt nix alter das
hat mir jetzt la was viel heftiger
walter hug ich fast gar kein leben mehr
april oder junger verpiss dich jetzt mal
war mir kurz auszeit machen hier ja
sicher machen der junge war ja ich bin
ganz aufgeregt als er hier sind krieger
und alle leute leute ich bin halt nicht
darunter geschubst ja selbst schuld wenn
wir nicht ausweichen kann stay
der krieg hat mich erst zur seite
gestoßen
mag ich sehr ich bin selbst ja wer
stacking league will also ich hab dich
gepumpt ich hab ich dich wie viel leben
hat es noch dicker viereinhalb und auch
als du mich verfolgt das allerdings
hatte voll
also ich hab mich verarscht ich dachte
das ist dann eben mal umdrehen aber dann
hat die spieler die schon unter
geschützt nächstes mal war richtig gut
gefightet hören hier aber good game
locker hätte hätte ich nicht erwartet
jung ich hab dich in zwei battles
[ __ ] also halt dein maul sogar in dem
dritten auch noch als allerdings als
finden dabei war wenn ich nicht ins
revier games noch fitter damit ich hier
der pro von uns aber ohne witz dass mit
dem einmal wollte ich auch noch machen
das hab ich gesagt ich habe meine sachen
um vergessen so das habe ich das meinte
ich da unten bogen wollte ich mir auch
machen aber auch leute alters war ein
episches battle ja also wir haben jetzt
zwei patzer der erste part war bis zu 18
minuten bei wir kurz auf torwart reißen
ja ja aber der erste partner 18 minuten
weil wieder halt ein bisschen gequatscht
haben dann war der zweite part halt dann
die restliche zeit halt also dann 15
minuten und das jeweils der dritte part
der final part leute wenn ihr mehr von
so was wollte das ist echt adrenalin pur
komm zu mir vor also ich bin echt am
schützen und für sich war kurzzeitig
echt so am zieht anne menschen was sie
dachte mir was darf ich darf mir nicht
erlauben dass ich jetzt verlieren weil
ich hatte diamond jazz plate und so was
alles ich hatte sogar noch ein ich habe
selbst noch ein feuerzeug dass ich von
dir
aber ich habe gut gekämpft na ja also
das taktisch gekämpft auf jeden fall
somit bogen und feuerzeug und lava da
habe ich zum beispiel an ein feuerzeug
und bogen habe ich erst am ende gedacht
und lahm habe ich zwar schon die ganze
zeit daran gedacht aber habe ich mich in
den iso darum gekümmert
ich halte ich habe mich halt wirklich
nur um diamanten gekümmert und das hat
er die ganze zeit nicht geklappt und
kurz dann als ich rausgehen wollte weil
ich in so eine schlucht rein und sie
einfach direkt drei verschiedene diamant
die zweige das war auch ob ich hier wo
ich gerade stehe hat der ist der kripo
explodiert hatten hier über geworfen da
kommt die spinne wobei nie was hier als
wenn die andere richtung da kommt die
spinne und stimmen mich hier als kind
habe ich war echt schon als du mich dann
angezündet tasten ich bin den berg hoch
gelaufen ich hatte nicht volles leben
sondern so zwei herzen abzug dann laufe
ich hier auf einmal was mich so eine
spinne so wieder ein herz abzuwenden von
trieb explodiert da dachte ich schon so
kalter das kann jetzt nicht mehr sein
dann laufe ich einfach den weg runter
habe ich dann gesehen wie du da und mit
einer spinne am kämpfen was dann hat es
mich hat mit dem bogen einmal getroffen
auf kurze range und dann noch mal hast
du mich dann angezündet und das dann
eher wenn du mich dann wenn du nicht
selbst angezündet worden während du
immer auf mich drauf gemacht hättest du
von allen möglichen seiten dann hättest
du glaub ich sogar gewonnen
ja auf jeden fall geld betteln ich würde
sagen weil mehr zeit kann es natürlich
auch besser vorbereiten mit drängten und
redstone fackeln vielleicht sonst was
alles wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
schreibt in die kommentare dank locker
schaffen wir schaffen wir 7775 daumen
hoch beiden videos er schaffte das wir
sind ihr seid die wissenschaft nicht hab
ich habe jetzt so langsam eilig und
gehen heute nochmal gekillt ist ein
gutes ende und patrick machst mich ja du
kannst von mir schon gar nicht bleibt
hier so lange bis ich tot bin es leute
danke fürs zuschauen war echt hammer
geil hat mega viel spaß macht und schau
[Musik]